here's what manager is like at one point
I made my car sighs shark leap out of
the water at the foot of a statue of a
horse I flopped around on the
cobblestones chasing and chomping drunk
revelers neither lack of limbs nor lack
of oxygen could deter me from my quest
to consume the people of the fictional
poor Clovis as I carried screaming
partiers back into the water to finish
them off actor Chris Parnell voiceover
narration filled in some interesting
details about the monument my
prehistoric killing machine was to
filing the spring of 73 was a magical
time in court Clovis when local favorite
trash-talk placed 20th in the Derby and
the city placed first in the country for
petty theft and that led to a new
holiday in the town since the local
population known for public drunkenness
and petty crime sprees was eager to
celebrate maneater provides a lot of
these kinds of moments mixing ridiculous
carnage and reality show absurdity to
create something hilarious it's
sometimes an uneven experience due
largely to frustrating combat and some
repetitive missions but the longer it
goes on the more fun maneater becomes
and its presentation keeps it from
getting stale
apart from the joy of eating people it's
the inspired presentation that really
makes man-eater work the game is framed
as if it's a cheap basic cable reality
show following your shark on its revenge
trip against an uncouth Cajun shark
hunter called scaly Pete think Deadliest
Catch meets planet Earth but much dumber
and goofier and narrated by giri from
Rick and Morty this is an adult [ __ ]
fast fierce and armed quite literally to
the teeth she has little to fear here in
the Gulf you're after Pete because he
killed your shark mom on the day you
were born
in response you bit off his hand then
began your quest to eat everything and
everyone you could in order to get huge
and exact vengeance as you swim through
the game's various biomes and eat
everything in sight Parnell's narrator
mixes actual shark facts or what sound
like facts at least with plenty of gags
at the expense of drunk and disorderly
poor Clovis Ian's wealthy shoreline
property owners humanity's exploitation
of the ocean and particularly boring
fish the perfusion of parrotfish here
have kept sapphire bays local hammerhead
healthy and strange-looking
the comedy is a huge part of what makes
maneater work because otherwise living
the shark life would probably be kind of
boring in each area of port Clovis your
goal is to complete a bunch of quests to
lure out the local apex predator and eat
it and to lure out some humans and eat
them in order to level up your shark and
gain new mutations that make you better
at heating stuff most of the quests are
pretty simple 810 of X fish eat 10
humans at X location eat X predator but
maneater keeps these quests pretty short
and manageable while mixing in comedy
and balancing them with a few other
activities each area has collectibles to
track down like landmarks both in and
out of the water that serve as
opportunities for more jokes and
pop-culture references you can track
down any tougher predators in the area
to test out your skills in combat and if
you chump enough humans port clovis will
send shark hunters after you like cops
in a Grand Theft Auto game those fights
can be even tougher as the hunters bring
along boats and automatic weapons but
play into the mayhem side of the game
where you can fling your shark through
the air to land on boats gobble the
hunters aboard and smash the vessels to
splinters
combat against dangerous creatures is
all about watching your enemy's
movements and getting in a few chops
when they're vulnerable a dedicated
dodge button helps you get out of the
way of attacks as creatures like
alligators and mako sharks start toward
you and as you gain mutations you get
perks that help you stun or poison prey
or absorb more damage you also regain
health by consuming fish so especially
in the early game victory is about
beating strategic retreats and eating
strategic treats to get back up to
fighting strength fighting and maneater
can be fraught when you're facing
predators since you and your enemies
dart toward each other like missiles and
frequently pass each other
maneater lets you Center the camera on
your enemy by clicking a control stick
or hitting a dedicated button on PC but
it lacks a true lock-on system for some
reason so it's easy to lose track of
what you're fighting and that can open
you up to vicious attacks and especially
in earlier shallower regions this can
make combat a bit of a mess the camera
can bump up against nearby land masses
which makes keeping track of your
attacker even tougher with little room
for evasion and if you hit the water
surface you get locked into an above
water view until you hit a specific
button to dive back down tearing you out
of combat even as the thing you're
fighting is gunning for you
fighting predators is a pain in the
early portion of the game especially but
gets better as you progress to the areas
with deeper water and earn mutations
that give you an edge all that eating
and destroying plays into the RPG side
of maneater where you gain nutrients to
level up your shark and the individual
mutations for each part of your body
once you unlock lots of mutations and
level them up they provide a strategic
component if you know you're going after
boats you'll want the strong and
defensive bone mutations equipped for
fighting predators the stunning powers
of the bioelectric set might be a better
choice it takes a while for the
mutations to really have a meaningful
effect on gameplay but once you start
maxing out upgrades they help create the
experience that is man-eaters beating
delicious heart making you into a huge
Ludacris nearly unstoppable killing
machine
the road shark must now be killed and
publicly displays to satisfy the city's
thirst for risen
man-eaters mayhem would work better on
the whole if not for the camera issues
the loose panicky nature of the combat
and some of the technical issues we
faced while playing at least on ps4 Pro
in certain biomes the framerate would
often take a dive which was especially
frustrating when trying to survive an
onslaught of hunters or a pack of
hammerheads
but we didn't see the same issues with
the Xbox one or PC versions I also ran
into a rare bug that wiped my save file
and another that broke a few
collectibles so that I couldn't unlock
all the mutations but developer tripwire
says both those issues have been fixed
with a launch day patch issues aside
man-eaters opportunities for shark chaos
can be a lot of fun but instead of a guy
running around with an arsenal of
weapons
you're a monster shark launching itself
30 feet into the air barrel rolling
straight through a boat and plucking
some screaming dork right off the bow
for good measure
with its sharply written hilariously
delivered narration and story beats to
freshen up the experience as you go
along maneater becomes a goofy fish
flopping romp with a good balance of
limbs to sever boats to wreak and
challenging creatures to render into
bite-sized chunks maneater isn't a
perfect shark simulator but it is a fun
and funny one who's positive adaptations
outpace its drawbacks
you
[Music]